From diana hunting sometimes.
Yeah,
man.
Come down.
A lot of wild pigs out here.
Alexandra [inaudible] ladies and gentlemen,
we're live.
Good to see you buddy.
What's happening?
I'm good.
You are you just recovering from shoulder surgery?
Did you show us what'd you have done?
Uh,
I was wrestling,
wrestling practice or I got taken down,
believe it or not,
I should slammed and I landed on,
I was,
I was like trying to post with my mom and I was slammed,
so just felt something in my shoulder basically.
And it didn't hurt it first I was trying to stand up and I felt it was just a
mess in there.
And after that I went through hospital and from there I've been,
I've been,
I've been rehabbing,
I got a plate inside.
Oh Wow.
Plate.
Yeah.
I took it out now in like,
uh,
ended last year,
but I had played for a couple of months.
Yeah.
What was the extent of the injury?
Uh,
nothing was broken.
It was more like the collarbone,
just,
just a dislocated,
they still get ripped apart from my shoulder,
so they had to put it back in.
But to play it on three screws down,
that's the first rule India had for my whole career.
I had Bruce's teachers and all that.
But this is the first real as probably not back,
but
pull this thing right in front of your face there.
So sorry if I,
this Sunday your viking beard's getting muffled.
So whether their tendons torn or ligaments,
ligaments,
10,
oh,
everything just torn apart.
Wow.
So they stitched it all back together again.
Put a plate in there.
Yeah.
And now I've just been,
I've been rehabbing,
I feel fine.
I'm 100% now,
so I'll be,
I'm,
I'm training.
So how many months was it?
Wow.
This happened in August and uh,
uh,
took away the plate and the last,
last year and I'd be rehabbing for a couple of months.
So yeah,
I have six months.
Totally.
Maybe.
Oh yes.
When you grabbed the bow and you're pulling it back,
I'm like,
maybe I shouldn't have him do that.
That's like,
you know that that kind of movement is like basketball sign.
No,
I'm good.
It's all good.
That's good.
The bowl was powerful.
I didn't expect though.
Yeah.
It's no joke.
It's good.
That's real shit.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
It's definitely good.
Like back training,
if you wanted to work on those muscles,
they're very specific.
100%.
Yeah.
But um,
so when you do that,
do you go through how you doing like platelet rich plasma and all sorts of
different therapies to try to accelerate the healing?
Well,
I had done,
I done,
I done my,
I'd done my physical rehab.
I've done a lot of like,
uh,
I don't know the word in English,
but a lot of acupuncture,
acupuncture.
Yeah.
A lot of,
a lot of massage,
a lot of rehab and lift in small weights.
Really boring stuff.
I hate that stuff.
I,
I had it so much,
but you just have to do it.
It's just tiny weights.
I started with that and then I'd just been increasing and Nah,
that's
it.
Welling ass rehabbing you.
I,
you know,
obviously I'm a big fan of yours and I was very worried when,
um,
after the clover to share a fight,
which I thought was like your masterpiece so far in your career.
Thank you.
Well,
it's just,
you've always been a very,
very good fighter,
but when you see a guy hit this new level,
and that's what I felt like you were in the Glover fight.
I was like,
Jesus Christ.
I like that combination that you finished him off with was that was some video
game shit.
That was crazy.
It was it like for yourself too,
right?
It was just standing there.
It was just standing there and I just,
yeah,
it's my show.
I hate my apricots.
Yeah.
I worked all night.
It was crazy.
Um,
but so then when I heard that you were injured after that,
I'm like,
ah,
Shit.
Like you were just catching your stride.
It was just,
so that's what I felt because I felt like I had,
I had,
everything's go,
I had such a flow in,
in training,
in,
in life generally.
Everything felt really good and I'm hungry.
I'll,
I was motivated.
I'm very motivated.
Uh,
but that,
that time after that,
that win and Glover is a tough opponent and everything went so well with the
fight and everything.
And,
and,
uh,
I felt really good.
And then this happened.
So,
so it was,
it was a big setback.
But,
uh,
what else in kill you makes you stronger,
right?
So I just kept working on it then,
and,
uh,
I just,
I just like,
I'm just,
I just looked forward and,
and uh,
I got a golden my site.
That's it.
Well,
the one thing that is good about something like that is it really gives you time
to pause and reflect and pay attention to all the other aspects of your game.
And you're such a foot work heavy movement,
heavy guy as my thing.
Yeah.
Well that's Sara.
It's so unusual for a guy as tall and as big as you to be so agile and have so
much footwork and movement.
I mean,
it must be a giant asset for you and fighting it is and feel for the Glover
fight.
I could do that for 10 rounds.
Uh,
you know,
I wasn't tired at all.
I would just,
I did my thing and I was out of there.
I wasn't in his pocket.
I listened.
He needs to arrange right now.
I did my thing again and I was out of there.
I could do that all night,
all night long and that,
that's also a thing like you always had it,
but after I fight,
I really felt that this,
this is working,
this is my thing and this is what I'm going to use and I'm going to get better
at it.
I'm going to get better than everything,
the whole game.
But this is my,
this is my key thing.
This is it.
And I know movement and footwork.
If I fought DC,
like I fought,
I fought Glover,
I'll beat him.
I'll be in all day long.
I'm telling you I'll beat him.
Well,
it was a very close fight the first time you guys find that,
but I still didn't,
I didn't do it enough,
man.
I was,
I was in his pocket too much.
One of the things that I really like about you,
Alex,
is that when you talk about yourself,
you're very hard on yourself.
You know,
like I'd like that one of the things that you said,
Z,
you're never satisfied.
This is the life of a high level athlete.
Never satisfied.
Never.
I just,
I just wanted to improve all the time and I always been the guy always been that
that person always had to take the hard way in stuff.
Learning,
learning new stuff all the time,
take the new,
uh,
the hard way.
You know?
I always had to take a beating with first before I win that that's,
that's how it's been.
And,
and uh,
and that just makes me stronger.
And I got the firing menu scrolls.
Yeah.
Well you're still young.
I mean,
how old are you now?
31 not that young.
That's young though.
I mean we think consider how long you've been fighting in the UFC.
I mean,
how old were you when you had your first fight in UFC 2120 does crazy.
10 years now.
That's crazy.
She's 10 years.
Do you think about yourself as 21 fighting in the UFC?
Like what it feels like?
But I think it's 10 years.
10 years.
She's always 10 years.
But it feels like it was yesterday.
I'm sure Tom runs in dispatch.
I'm thinking in this business,
because your life is,
it's all about the next fight.
It's always planning for the next flight,
the next flight.
So Jason,
we're just passing me by.
Well,
you also have constant growth and improvement,
but it gets tested in these big jumps like every three times a year,
two times a year,
whatever it is.
Your schedule that you're fighting on.
Yeah.
You get these big tests and you get to find out how applicable everything that
you've worked on is.
Yeah,
yeah.
That's,
that's how it is.
And,
and,
and you,
you feel,
you feel off that test.
You just fill out,
okay,
what's next?
Yeah.
What should I do next?
What?
What's the,
what's the nest improvement?
What's the best,
what's the nest opponent?
Uh,
where's the belt?
Well,
stuff like that,
you know,
when you get off of like,
you had like one of the most spectacular fights with Jon Jones.
I mean,
down to the wire,
like is as close as it gets.
And when you get out of a fight like that,
will you all most won the title against the greatest of all time?
Like what is,
what is that feeling like and where do you go from there?
Uh,
Oh,
you know,
it was tough.
It was really tough because I know everybody was saying,
are you winning this fight?
Winning this fight?
You had three rounds against him.
Now you winning this fight,
the lie,
if it felt like,
like you said,
it was something,
it was just,
it was just right there at the goal line.
You know,
I didn't really pass that goal nine at all.
Um,
I just felt like that it was tough.
It was tough,
but by,
but like now I'm sitting here now talking to you.
It's a big,
it's a really good experience for me and in our really,
it's a good time for me.
If I was a,W is a highlight in my career for sure in my life,
for sure.
It was such a close fight when the,
when the scorecards are being tagged and you,
uh,
you know,
you're just sitting there waiting for the decision.
Did you think you hadn't,
you know,
I didn't know.
Right.
I did know much chaos.
Could you even remember what had happened over the last five rounds?
I remember,
I remember the,
I remember the fight,
uh,
and I got a,
I remember almost the whole fight,
but it was just John Jones just such a basis.
He,
you know,
I'm telling you,
just for me,
John,
John's winning over John Jones is bigger than taking the belt.
I'm telling you that guys,
the guy is such a beast and,
and uh,
yeah.
What was the question?
No,
it's okay to express yourself.
That's fine.
I mean,
I agree with you.
He is a beast.
You know,
I'm,
I'm very disappointed with all the stuff that's happened to him obviously,
and especially the most recent one,
which I really,
I really believe based on the evidence as a mistake,
I think,
I think he got ahold of something tainted because of they,
they tested him before that he was negative.
They tested them after that he was negative and what he tested for,
with such a minuscule amount,
there's no way.
It was something that,
yeah,
there's no way,
like according to Novitsky and according to Usada according to like how they
test people,
what,
whatever he consumed must have been an extremely small amount.
It wasn't an amount that would have had any benefit whatsoever in terms of
performance,
performance enhancing.
Well they know their thing.
So you know,
just let the experts handle that.
I don't know what to say.
I know for a fact that he's been in that same situation a couple of times.
This is not the first time.
So,
you know,
it's just,
he definitely is a wild motherfucker.
Hayes Hayes is,
it definitely does.
Some shitty probably shouldn't do but 100% man.
But uh,
I mean,
but the thing is,
it's so stupid because he's,
what is he?
He's the best guy pound for pound
out there.
He's done things nobody else has done is he,
he's just a beast and still shit just comes up all the time.
He doesn't even need that steroids.
So it doesn't even need that shit in him.
He's still the best out there.
I don't think he took anything.
I really don't.
But I,
but I agree with you on that and I think you need a guy like that.
You need a guy like that out there,
like to bring you to your full potential.
Do you agree?
Yeah,
I agree with you.
Yeah.
Like I said to you,
fighting him and beating him,
that's bigger than taking the bumps right now.
That's how I feel.
Because he's,
look what it did to DC,
man.
Yeah.
This is tough history that he finished DC.
Yes.
That's just insane.
It's just insane.
And he finished him with a kick that DC said he's never going to hit him with
crazy.
That's insane.
Yeah.
It's like you're never going to hit me with that left thigh kick lamb.
Just look for the opportunity to takes it.
Yeah.
Tendencies are crazy.
It's just some of them just get so ingrained in the way your body moves and you
know,
he's,
he,
he's an expert.
What of course,
what he's doing and he's,
he's studying his opponent very well.
Uh,
everything is still such planet in details for the fights and he just,
he knows exactly.
He should go for that or that or that.
And staying creative and use news fantasy.
And it's amazing to see.
Yeah,
that Jackson John Team is truly exceptional team.
I mean,
they really did do phenomenal with him.
Now where you're at now is a very interesting situation because John is in
exile.
No one knows what's going to happen in terms of how long it's going to be
suspended.
DC is now fighting steep Emile chips for the heavyweight title.
And who knows what's happening there.
I mean that,
does that bother you because it seems like it Kinda like puts the two oh five
title in limbo.
It does.
Yeah,
it does.
I didn't see that coming at all.
This is typified at all.
You know,
it's a,
it's a great fight for,
for them and for the financing,
for the spoiled,
you know,
for us standing,
standing in line,
we just,
you know,
we're just sitting there on our,
on our,
we just sitting there and waiting for him for an opportunity and it's not going
to come.
It's not going to be there.
So,
and all and,
and,
and uh,
you know,
I,
I wa that that's also a thing that had been motivated me a lot because
often if I were glove,
I got engine and,
and all that and I was really looking forward to come back and,
and,
and make,
make a really strong,
uh,
performing very strong next performance.
I just really wanted to,
I had my eyes on that goal and,
and uh,
and then the,
they met,
I actually count and almost,
uh,
you know,
fighting DC,
but then,
then it was all gone by him going up the step.
And so,
so it's,
it's a crisis situation.
The whole division is just crazy right now.
Yeah,
it really is because that fight is not even going to take place until July.
So here we are in April,
May,
June,
July,
we are three months till that fight takes place that fight and then obviously at
least three months,
most likely more before the title could be challenged again.
So that's,
we don't even know if it's coming,
if it comes back.
Right.
He might notice what happens in that fight unless once he gets used to eating
again,
like you know,
it's going to be a tough one.
You see wins.
I see it in pictures now.
You know,
I'm going to meet him a couple of days.
It looks a little bit,
you know,
heavy right now.
Well he was a on TV the other day eating potato chips and you're in a cab.
No,
he loved that.
Yeah.
He loves food,
that's for sure.
I mean,
and uh,
I,
you know,
you look back at his performance in strike force as a heavyweight and it was
phenomenal.
Good,
good,
phenomenal.
If you didn't lose,
he didn't lose that heavyweight and he's good tossed around gorillas like Josh
Barnett lift him up like nothing crazy.
It'll be this fight against TTIP is,
uh,
you know,
if it will be another,
I guess another heavyweight,
I'll probably 60 people are going to win this fight.
But do you see,
is like you said,
he's,
he's a really good heavyweight,
so when those,
what happens?
Well,
his wrestling is just so next level.
It's such a,
it's an interesting position because Steve Bay is a very good wrestler.
But of course DC's worldclass today's world class and he,
he doesn't take one step back.
May just comes out to he's being,
he's just in your face.
And it's tough to count out Steve Bay too,
because Steve Bay is though pound for pound consensus.
Best heavy weight ever.
I mean,
the guy has defended the title more than anybody.
You look at his resume,
it's impeccable.
And Max out a junior dos Santos knocks out Overeem a beats Francis in Ghana who
was everybody's scared of.
I mean,
he's a bad ass.
Yeah.
So you know,
but the seats,
he such a competitive guy,
he does,
he doesn't want,
he doesn't take a step back and he just goes for it.
Even if,
even if Tufts situation,
he's just,
he just eats it and comes back and do what to do always.
And then for being a fat guy,
that guy,
that guy works,
he's screaming at you right now.
Hey man,
settle down.
But that guy is,
he's doing fire rounds.
Like nothing.
Yeah.
So the conditioning is some top.
Yeah,
he just eats the wrong food.
That's all it does.
Yeah.
I mean,
I mean maybe some of it's genetic.
I just think it as eating the wrong food.
I mean there's evidence.
Sure.
Chips.
Yeah.
I mean there was evidence.
It's not like I'm just talking out of my ass.
I've seen him eat the wrong food and me too.
But yeah,
nothing but respect for that guy.
He's an awesome human being to see is just fantastic guy.
Have you ever thought about fighting heavyweight?
Cross my mind from time to time,
but I feel I'm,
I'm not done with not done in light type way yet.
I have still things to do.
What do you walk around at?
How I'm heavy.
I'm heavy like what I'm calling DCFS but probably shouldn't say anything.
Yeah.
But you have been in America for two days.
I can directly compounds being here.
All our GMO food flux.
So like what,
what,
when you normally are getting down to two oh five what do you walk around at
two you know,
maybe I'll stop my camps to 35 really?
Wow.
Yeah.
I go up to two photos sometimes.
No kidding.
Wow.
Oh,
you healthy at two 40 or are you just like,
I moved like never before.
It's crazy.
Really?
Yeah,
I do.
I've got some speed in my,
my,
my footwork.
I just do you feel good at two 40?
I feel pretty good being heavy.
I do.
And,
and I feel strong.
I feel strong.
I spawn big guys.
I was pulling heavy guys and I feel really strong in being a heavyweight,
but,
but uh,
like I told you,
man,
I'm,
I'm not finishing right yet.
I understand.
But how much of you gets diminished in that cut to two?
Oh five.
Not that bad.
It's like,
you know,
when I stopped because of Csun,
I do,
maybe off season,
I do eight to 10 sessions a week.
Uh,
I don't stress,
you know,
I don't eat shit food.
I of course I,
sometimes I drink a couple of bears,
so I have a pizza,
whatever,
you know,
I'm a have to live sometimes,
but,
uh,
it's a good,
good,
good regular meals.
Uh,
doing a little bit,
lifting some,
some,
some weights.
And,
uh,
and I,
and when I started,
when I stopped my camps,
it's like my body feels like,
okay,
it's time now to start working here and,
and I start doing my sprints and my,
my,
my miles on the treadmill.
Um,
you know,
from one week to another I maybe lose like 10 pounds.
It's crazy.
It's,
it's like my bud just knows,
okay,
it's time to work and then I drips,
drops like nothing.
Wow.
So you bought it just accustomed to your job and I fit.
It's because,
you know,
I've done it many times.
So it's just like,
you know the routines.
No.
I know you do a lot of hunting and you were showing me some photos before the
podcast.
Do you incorporate wild game into your diet?
That's all I do.
Yeah.
I wouldn't say never,
but I barely buy anything from the store when it comes to meat or all that.
I just hadn't,
I just hunt everything I eat.
I tried to support my family with,
with,
with the,
with what I'm hunting,
you know,
we got to,
I'm hunting a lot of wild boars.
We have what a lot of water bores and Sweden,
I'm a hunting days.
We got to read their fellow.
There's a,
we got Moose.
Uh,
and you can't compare the meat.
It's as long as it's,
it's a,
it's a science just to cook it.
Right.
But if you cook it right and,
and you know what you're doing,
it's the best thing ever.
Yeah,
I agree.
And I've always wondered like as a professional athlete what it would be like,
like whether or not you see the benefit in eating such protein rich,
nutrient dense meat as opposed to pasture raised or farming know I can compare
it.
We can't compare it.
And,
and,
and everything around it too.
You know,
it,
they've suffering,
they do it like it's not a good,
it's not a good business.
You know,
I don't like that based on it.
I don't want to support it all.
So I read it to my hunting.
No,
I agree.
And I mean there's,
to me it's the best way.
If you're going to eat meat,
it's absolutely the best way.
But what I'm thinking is like,
I don't know a lot of pro athletes that only eat wild game and only hunt wild
game,
but I would think that there would be a great benefit in that 100%,
100%.
You can't get better nutrition to your body than eating,
eating that meat.
It's the best thing there is.
And I feel even like,
just how do you feel after eating?
Like,
uh,
like,
for,
for uh,
uh,
a 400 gram steak all through eating like a 400 gram,
whatever dear readers you've been hunting,
you don't feel the same.
It all for you don't feel tired.
He don't feel like you're getting this food coma and stuff like that.
You feel fresh.
Yeah.
Fresh.
It's weird,
right?
It's a wild game.
Has Almost an invigorating sensation to it when they need it actually feels you
feel and you feel strong.
You feel good about doing it.
How long have you been hunting?
I've been hunting since a kid.
Grow up on a form and,
and,
and my,
my dad was hunting a lot when I was a kid and then I didn't hunt for,
for a long time.
And I get back to 2012
actually,
I took my license and,
and uh,
just an off than I had been hunting.
If I don't train,
I'm outdoors.
If I don't train on outdoors and we have seasons in Sweden,
so it's not like you're hunting all year round,
but uh,
but I'll make sure I,
I feel the freezer on the Dell seasons.
Um,
so yeah.
And I'm not training on hunting.
That's awesome.
Well,
you don't use bowls there though.
It's not easy.
It's not on the guns.
A lot of European countries.
I know in Spain it's legal.
I,
yeah.
In Spain where you said you hunted those red deer.
Yeah.
Can I have a friend of mine who lives in Spain and he's a big bow hunter.
Oh,
okay.
Yeah.
No,
it's only rifles and Sweden.
Yeah.
But that works too,
man.
It works.
Yeah.
I mean,
it's the most effective way for sure.
And obviously it shoot them at a higher distance and it is,
a lot of people think it's more humane to,
if you're not good with a bow there.
Right?
Yeah,
yeah.
You know,
but when it comes to the feeling of being outdoors,
being close to the,
to,
to the being close to the animal and stuff like that,
I don't even think you can compare it to,
to,
to actually the bow hunting.
It's a whole night of technique is how the way to to hunt.
Well guy like you who loves challenges,
who thrives off of that you would do with thrive.
I've done it,
but if,
if I,
if I tried,
I probably love it.
This is a man.
I'll hook you up.
I appreciate that at all.
On the back I'll be back and my friend John Dudley is tall like you too.
So He'd be the perfect guy to coach you.
He,
it sounds great to you and take you out on a hunt.
Yeah.
Now I can't wait man.
I love that.
Well,
especially wild pigs.
There's a place that he has an Oklahoma that uh,
they,
they hunt a lot of wild pigs.
I mean they just have to eradicate them.
There's so many of them.
I heard about it.
Yeah,
it's too many.
It's too many.
It's,
I heard it's,
and how the anthem to is kind of crazy.
Oh,
the ones in Texas where the deaf from helicopter,
I saw that on youtube channels and stuff like that going crazy down there.
They just have to,
I mean Texas is so big and there's so many pigs.
There's millions and millions of pigs there.
And they're constantly breeding.
Yeah.
They'll have like three,
four little g year and each litter they'll have four,
six piglets and they just keep going and going and going and going and it just
no end or,
whoa.
And they don't have very many predators.
A few mountain lines take them out occasionally.
Yeah.
For the most part,
they just running and gunning and they keep breeding.
Did it get big in here?
They do big several halls.
Pounds.
Yeah.
It was common to see three,
400 pound pigs.
Well in Sweden,
Sweden,
there we have a couple of them,
but they don't get that big though.
And the thing is,
how are we hunting in Sweden is when the farmers,
when they,
you know,
they had all their acres and all the,
the lands,
they actually called us in because the pigs to help them out.
Then we just,
I'll do it all night.
The Sun never goes down.
And Sweden in summertimes.
Oh really?
Now we had like a midnight sun.
So it,
it's so cozy being out there.
It's kind of warm.
It's nice you going around checking the lance and it's pretty good man.
You would like it.
I'm sure I would.
I've only been to Sweden once for the UFC when I was there,
but I loved it.
Them beautiful city.
Fantastic.
Really,
really enjoyed
it there.
Thank you.
Very nice people too.
Oh,
they are?
We are.
So,
so how did you get aligned with alliance?
How did that,
how did that wind up happening where you started coming to America to train and
how far into your career was that right off the full fight.
Really?
Yeah.
Right off the fill fight.
And back then we didn't,
we didn't have those resources in,
in,
in Stockholm at all.
And you say Phil Davis,
we're talking about on the full is also an alliance fighter.
Yeah.
Which is pretty cool man.
That you guys fought and then you went to train with them.
Yeah.
What,
how,
how'd that work out?
It wasn't good.
You know,
he,
he just kicked my ass to for the first couple of times before I foster learning
the whole wrestling part and yeah.
How even to defend a take down and then after that I just become good at and,
and uh,
I really enjoy enjoying coming,
coming down here,
meeting the guys and train and it's a whole nother type of life.
Well,
it's so cool that he accepted you after you were opponent too.
And how'd you come and learn with them?
Yeah,
we do.
We just talked off to the fight right away and,
and uh,
you know,
I just,
I just swallowed my pride and I would just talk to them,
talk to him after the fight and I know he invited me over and,
and uh,
I can,
we just can,
meaning my culture just came over and we had no idea what to expect.
And I remember we just,
we just landed now we landed at nighttime,
so we went to the gym to sleep.
I woke up the day after and I was hitting someone hitting the bags down there,
like in the math area early now,
super early.
I'm like,
who's this?
I went down,
it was filled,
it was hitting the bags and I felt so like,
oh damn,
I have to do this too.
After that we started to like,
you know,
trying to get it.
So it was a really good time.
And then he came actually down to to us to help me out with,
we'd love to share too.
So he went to Sweden?
Yeah,
yeah,
for a couple of weeks.
So any fault.
Love it too.
And that and you know,
it's,
it means so much to me to have these guys training with me,
you know,
with feel illy Latifi we have Jimmy Montoya and all those go such great guys and
love training with them and it makes,
it makes my training just,
I just upset,
you know,
steps up even more.
We have,
we have bunch of guys,
we have like Russian companies.
We established a really good place now.
It all starts in,
in Sweden and Europe,
around around Europe and and getting so much good guy in my,
in my level of firing just rises to the top man.
I'm telling you if,
if I,
if I spar with field Jimmy or,
or earlier,
I just feel like every day,
every day's a fight.
You know,
you,
you can be relaxed.
You can't just throw,
Jab and don't care about the calendar.
You have to such amazing training.
Fantastic too.
Over the last decade,
the level of talent that's coming out of Europe has just escalated.
It's been so different.
It's so big.
And the wrestling too,
which is a big part of it.
So much more wrestling.
So much.
So much more talent.
I exactly know.
We know we have,
we have,
we have guys coming from,
from,
from Hispanic Estann.
We have different Russian countries down there to coming in and they'll guys a
beast beast and they're there.
The drive in there,
they're the double legs to take downs stay.
And the Ed charts though they chose,
they take it like nothing and they just comes out too.
So they make,
they make me work a lot and yeah,
that's exactly what I need.
Exactly what I need.
Yeah.
That's been one of the more interesting things over the last five or six years
is the rise of the Russians and so many from the Soviet,
former Soviet Union.
Yep.
Yeah.
Now they're there and they have such a,
there's such a working capital capacity.
They work a lot.
We have a couple of guys down at the gym now and you know,
they're,
that's the gym.
When I come to the gym,
that the gym,
when I leave the gym and never leave that way,
they live in their dollar.
So they never leave basically.
But,
but in the last,
so they actually do,
we have a facility that we,
so people can stay and,
and,
you know,
train.
So that's excellent.
Yeah.
So,
but they,
they just work,
man.
We work all day long.
That's a great asset to have a facility where people can train and live there.
I know American top team puts something like that in Winkeljohn and um,
uh,
Greg Jackson put something like that and yeah,
that,
that's got to help so much where young guys who don't have much money but you
know,
100% train 100%,
it's a really good way to also to,
you know,
give something back,
man.
It's,
you know,
the,
they,
they have their rooms to sleep in.
We manage.
So they,
they have really good foods in,
you know,
to,
to bring lunches and stuff.
Uh,
so,
uh,
we also go at it.
We've also got it from here because we,
at the beginning,
when we came to San Diego,
like I saw it,
it was another top of training,
not the type of lifestyle.
And we sold that.
Me and my coach.
There's Michael.
So,
uh,
we just,
after doing this years and years and years,
uh,
we now manage to do it at home and I just love it.
You know,
I'll be,
I'll be traveling.
I've been traveling all my,
all my career to,
to,
to America to train and around the place.
So I now we established a good,
good training system that works and we establish it good.
And I feel great to be home,
Eh,
you know,
when you're getting the faculty and stuff.
I'm 31 years old and it works,
man.
It works.
I know it'd been as that shape on my life then I've been like training at home
and feeling good.
That's fantastic.
We don't have to drain yourself by flying over across the country,
staying somewhere you don't know.
Exactly.
Yeah.
You're a real pioneer in terms of like European mixed martial arts.
What is it like now seeing all this sort of explode around you?
I mean,
it's become so popular all over the world now.
I mean MMA from when you started 10 ago to now,
it's barely recognizable.
No,
you're with a gangster back down.
Yeah.
Oh,
you're a psychopath.
Either one or two of those when you're training like,
and yeah,
but nowadays it's amazing.
You know,
you have a walk around in the stall,
Coleman and,
and people are John Keys.
They know even more than I know about techniques,
about,
about the sport we have all ladies and gentleman is coming in one,
one an autograph or a picture.
It's,
it's grown so much.
it's,
uh,
like you say,
it's been expelled it all over the world.
Now what I was getting at was that when you first started out,
how much of a structure was in place?
Like in terms of like how much strength and conditioning you should do,
how much sparring you should do,
how much drilling you should do.
You know,
I just,
I let,
I let undressed Michael to handle that to me.
He's,
he's,
he's a,
he's a mastermind.
I'll coaching.
He,
he,
he puts me in situations and off I hit him.
[inaudible] is the worst ever.
I'm thinking we'd be in a session.
We all have been fighting sometimes and I'll be like,
uh,
by,
it has this old mentality of training.
Uh,
he doesn't do,
we don't do too much of the scientific thing.
Like with,
you know,
you watch your poles,
your,
your measure,
you think we just do the hardcore things.
And of course we do that to the scientific a little bit,
but not too much.
So we're trying to balancing out,
uh,
but just we,
yeah,
he plans everything out.
He's a mastermind of coaching and he knows me in and out and I know him.
That's another very important part in the development of young fighters is
having someone that they can entrust that has knowledge where it's an Eric del
Faro or Andreas or you know,
Jackson Winkeljohn,
like whoever it is,
like having someone who really understands the sport,
who can guide you.
Yeah.
And that's just such a giant resource for a guy.
It is.
And you know,
as this port explodes and get bigger,
you have those fake ones coming in and think they know everything,
you know,
and,
and they,
they wanted to be up.
They want to have piece of the cake basically.
Yeah.
While we have like these guys like Gary [inaudible] and undressed Michael and
their,
their masterminds man,
what is this,
what is his background?
He was a professional boxer.
Yeah.
Like he here's like 19 or 20,
no boxing record.
So,
and then he broke his arm and he had to finish by,
has to finish Korea because he's here,
he's arm.
But uh,
now he's,
uh,
he does,
he does his background and that's where I got my footwork from because you know,
that's what I'm got my,
my bay foundation in firing from.
And then,
um,
then I,
I also,
one thing about Bob bought a coach,
uh,
like [inaudible] for example,
he or Eric to there,
they don't,
they don't care about the glory.
They don't care about the attention,
you know,
they,
they don't care about the,
they are the head cultures by they,
they take in,
if they are honest to,
to,
to me and to themselves or not.
I don't know these things.
I know the graph,
the graph
and things,
I don't know.
The rest of the things they learn is they learn to as it as it grows and they
learn with me,
but they take in people that you know,
so that we cover the whole thing because what we've covered the whole,
the whole,
all the aspects of the game basically.
So yeah,
Eric is one of the most important,
but yet the most humble guys.
Yeah.
He's super humble is very in the background.
There's a few guys like that that I really respect.
John Crouch from the MMA lab,
he's very similar to,
they're not looking for attention,
just laying back and there's a lot of guys that get that aren't looking for
attention that just get it because they're so good.
Like for us,
a hobby you can keep going on and on.
There's a lot of them,
but those guys are so important.
I mean it's so critical like finding a big camp with great fighters and a
fantastic coaching staff as well.
They're the difference between you realizing your full potential and not that
that's sometimes is the difference that's having the right coaches to keep
basically,
yes.
The Qi coaches and training partners?
Yeah,
a hundred percent yeah.
Now,
so you,
you give him like full reign in terms of like everything you do.
I would discuss it all the time.
We argue sometimes we were hugging sometimes.
You know,
it's,
it's like a relationship man.
It's my,
it's my,
it's my family too.
So that's how you know,
that's all it is.
I remember we had a,
we had a really good,
we were in Vegas actually for camp.
I thought I was fine.
Kevin Silver and uh,
he was putting me in there in the cage with some big as real estate's.
I wasn't and I was,
I wasn't too far to 35 back then.
I was like two 2119 walking around with these guys was heavy,
big American heavyweights,
good wrestling guy.
And there was just taking me down and taking me down,
like submitting me and I was like a study.
I stand up in the case,
I'll throw all of them.
I think it's enough.
I can't take it,
let me out,
let me out of the case.
So I was hitting the door.
I wanted us to reject.
The Gym was full of people now,
so everybody just froze looking at me like,
and the case was like on a pedestal so everybody could see me.
So I was hitting the door and I see on reality is outside of the,
he's like doing this dope.
He's standing there while I'm moron,
yelling so blows through.
Meanwhile,
when you took John Jones down,
you had to be thinking,
God damn glad I didn't open up that door.
I was surprised from that.
When I ended up in that position on top of him,
like Shamir Shit out of me,
the this really happened.
I didn't think you were going to go for it.
So when you went for it and then took him down,
we were all like,
oh shit.
I was shocked.
I was.
I was laying on top and I'm like,
wow,
I have,
I'm an extra on top.
I'm a top of this guy.
I didn't even think that was possible,
but it wasn't that too hard to take.
I think Darlene caught them by surprise.
Yeah,
I did.
I was,
it was pretty awesome.
I think it was a price to,
yeah.
Yeah.
Well it was a pretty fucking awesome.
Now what does a
typical day in your,
uh,
in your camp?
Like do you,
do you break up conditioning days with skill work days?
Do you do conditioning in the morning?
Do you do it in after you're done where your skill work?
How do you work that?
I do,
I do
from 10 to 12 sessions a week on when I'm in camp,
I tried to,
we have,
we have actually the,
the group that we had the group workouts with the whole group,
the holiday wreath group,
uh,
in the mornings and then we do everything from sparring too,
too.
Good kickboxing grills too.
Yeah,
whatever.
That's when the group is,
is training and that's,
that's it's all the time.
It's the same group at the same time every morning.
And then the nighttime is more like individual,
okay,
what I'm doing today.
Yeah.
You'd maybe do five,
five rounds of pants and they need to do sprints or it could be either one or
strength or,
yeah,
it could be the one.
So that's how we,
that's how we,
how we do it basically.
So do you have a separate Jujitsu coach?
Separate Moy Thai coach?
Like how do you,
how do you work all that stuff out?
Yeah,
the guy that was with me now,
the Joakim Karlsson,
he's actually the,
the,
the national,
uh,
the national coast of Thai boxing.
And he's coaching me in,
in my,
in my cakes and my niece and my,
in my kickbox.
And then I,
I learn Nascimento.
It's a Brazilian,
he lives in.
I'd been living in Sweden many years and as a family and everything.
So he's having,
he asked my Jujitsu and my grappling and he is such a competitive guy.
He's still,
he's still competes.
It beats me up in e sports with me,
basically like a,
his spouse with me.
And it just,
it makes me learn the hard way.
So you've got just done an amazing staff over there.
Amazing stuff.
It's amazing stuff.
That's fantastic.
I love it.
And so when you say you do these 10 to 12 sessions per week,
do you have like a,
a board up on the wall?
You outlined the week ahead or do you do it day by day?
How do you do that?
I'll get a text from Andreas.
This is the way I just,
I just awaiting from that takes math but the Silas and fuck up my phone.
Like I don't want to see it,
but I have to know so,
so,
so that's how it works.
They give me
text.
If,
if we do it could be on the board to have a big wipe board on the,
on the,
on the wall.
He could be on the world too.
He puts down the session.
If it's something's particularly,
we are maybe sparring commoning we have to adapt the schedule a little bit
different.
It's a different one every week.
So
yeah,
I could imagine.
I would imagine it gets,
I used to training.
Yeah,
still train.
I've got some serious injuries and I'm trying to heal up right now though.
It was dangerous to,
uh,
problems.
Uh,
one big one is I got tendinitis in my elbow.
I've never had tendinitis before and don't know what that is.
It's fucking strain and the tendon that just does if you tendance of low blood
supply.
So the problem with tendinitis is it takes forever to heal.
And I didn't overstretch the alarm.
It was a from pulling from cleans and from Chin.
This one on the inside this,
this muscle right here or this tendon right here.
Man,
I fucked it up.
I just,
I kept training with it.
I kept getting information in a real bad to the point where it wasn't healing
and I did stem cells and PRP.
I finally got ahold of it,
but it's this thing right here.
I keep it with me all the time.
This helped me more than anything.
It's a thing called the theraband and what you do is you hold it because it's
on,
this is the elbow that's injured.
So I hold it out like this,
I twist it and then I slowly untwisted with this side and that therapy,
just doing this,
I do this like five,
six times a day.
I'll do like 10 reps.
That's been like the best thing that's helped me more than anything.
Will you be able to trend now or new?
You'll be soon.
Pretty soon.
I think I'm good.
In about two weeks.
I'm going to give myself two more weeks as kicks.
Oh,
thank you.
That's what I heard.
I'll show you.
I can still kick,
but now I have no problem with my kid.
Yeah,
I'm very public.
Cool.
I did taekwondo when I was a little kid.
I started out with that and then you know,
got into Moitai later,
but yeah.
Cool.
I have to,
I have to strike for an hour before the workouts.
Really?
Yeah.
I think it's,
I don't know.
I think it's from my genetics or something.
I'm just a stiff vikings.
I'm telling Aaron Swartz,
swinging Swartz,
kick over your knees.
I can only move fast pretty much.
That's all.
Yeah,
but I guarantee you you could improve that flexibility.
That's the thing.
I have that through my whole career.
I was just working on my,
my flexibility and I went out.
When I'm,
when I'm stepping in that Octagon,
I'm flexible as hell.
But that's just two times a year ago.
So
full peak in the full peak of camp and you're flexing this,
I leave the cases.
Are you doing a lot of weightlifting?
Is that what it is?
You're doing lot of squats or dead lifts?
It seemed like they're negative because I think I just,
I'm,
I'm super stoked.
It depends on not stiff everywhere.
He's just,
my hamstrings are stiff.
When did you start martial arts?
Uh,
for real when I was starting him in May,
2000 end of 2006 really?
Okay.
So it was fairly late in life.
It was,
I've been boxing and stuff,
but that's just being an amateur level.
I don't even count that as a,
as a,
as a series doing sport thing.
It was just fucking around.
Yeah,
just be painting.
So you were basically like 18,
19 when you really got into it around there.
Yeah.
So your body already matured.
See One of the things that you see about kicking in particular is when you get
young fighters before their bodies matured,
then their flexibility usually stays.
You know,
like if you start karate or something like that.
Could Phil Davis for example,
that guy,
he's massive.
Bastille is flexible as it's great.
It's like a fucking stud out too.
He looks like Superhero.
I know.
Like he limited his waist to shoulder ratio.
It same with Jim.
Even though Jim and Manuel,
I don't put up my teacher when I'm training with him.
I don't want to just get hoodie on me.
It's keeping my hoodie on.
Say with the field guys are jacked.
Yeah,
I know.
Even if they're off season,
that's the thing.
I just get him Chubby or like a big,
big s the former body and these guys,
they're like,
it looks like athletes all round.
Man.
Is that frustrating?
Sometimes,
but it's that just genetic of though when I went into the wrong
fat guy,
fat guys all over the world.
Yeah.
Um,
so do you,
do you like,
do you watch your diet at all outside of a camp?
I do.
I do actually I do.
I tried to,
I tried to stay away from sugar,
sugar.
I don't,
uh,
when I do sugar,
if I do like sodas and stuff like that,
eye candy,
whatever,
I,
I gain a lot of weight.
But as soon as I quit it,
I just crazy as I drop in weight,
sugar is the devil.
It is.
I hate children.
That's the worst.
It's the worst when you realize what it's actually doing to your body and you
realize it's everywhere.
And that most people that you run into are just eating sugar all day long and
it's crashing.
Doesn't taste that good if you don't do it right.
That's the weird thing,
right?
Once your gut bacteria,
because acclimated to eating healthy food,
you start craving salads and shit.
Yeah.
It's weird,
right?
Yeah.
So now when you talk about flexibility,
do you ever do yoga?
I don't.
You don't know?
I don't like that
Vikings in Yoga don't mix.
No.
I,
I think it just because I'm so bad at it.
Um,
you know,
and you need patient,
a lot of patients doing it.
And I wish,
I wish I liked it.
I wish I,
because I would probably,
I would probably needed more than ever,
but he's still,
it don't get me wrong.
Um,
uh,
you know,
I stretch,
I do my flexible things in my training and all that,
but yeah,
I put a whole workout in just to,
just to stretch your body.
Um,
I dunno.
I don't have the patience for it.
It's not just that though.
That's what's interesting about it.
It's a strengthening thing too.
Just strengthens your body in an unusual way.
Um,
I've seen a lot more fighters getting involved in it and really seeing benefits.
One of them was a Nathan Corbett,
you know Nathan Corbett,
the mortar champion.
Yeah,
I heard along.
He's doing some interview recently and talking about how much yoga he does and
how much it's helped his power and helped this movement.
No,
I believe it does.
Based on that.
Interested probably have to think about it.
What I was thinking,
God like you,
who's so driven and trying to succeed at all costs,
like trying to figure out what's the best way to succeed.
You might want to investigate that.
I should,
I should actually do it.
I should do it.
I think it will.
I think I will,
you know,
people telling me,
they telling me like my cakes,
I have to work on my case more.
You have to use my kicks more than fights.
They all right.
I need to start doing my kicks.
Mourn the thing.
I kick butt.
I kicked with a soda and maybe uh,
unsecurity I dunno.
I I love,
I love,
I think it is from,
from back in the days when I was getting taken down all the time doing my kicks.
But
nowadays people taking me down,
but um,
you know,
they can't hold me down.
Nobody if to take me down,
nobody can hold me down.
So this is something I need to like start doing even more,
not just kick into the,
to the legs are,
you know,
more powerful kicks to the body.
My knees are good.
I worked on my niece all the time and I'm,
I'm,
I'm putting in more in my fights and allow needs.
Um,
I'm,
I'm getting really high with my niece was fine.
You'd have chains about MMA and martial arts in general is that there's always
room for improvement.
There's always things to work on.
No one is the best at everything.
Even if you are 31 years old,
you're doing this for 10 years,
you still have so much to learn.
That's the,
that's the good thing with the sport.
No,
it's a,
it's such a comprehensive sport.
I mean,
I really don't think people appreciate how much thought is involved in the
preparation.
Yeah,
no,
it's,
it's a lot.
It's a lot.
So how long do you think you'll be doing it?
You say 31 like you're old,
you're not,
it seems like you've been doing it a long time,
right?
Yeah.
How many years do you think you have left?
I,
I feel I feel really hungry and motivated.
I don't think the age is going to be I,
I don't,
I don't think,
uh,
my age in terms of,
you know,
have pain in your body or injuries,
anything like that is going to stop me.
It's more like,
as long as I'm having fun,
as long as I'm enjoying what I'm doing,
I'll do it.
You'll have,
you have guys that are like doing it late in to,
that's also a good thing with the sport.
It's such a guy,
such an old age of,
of,
of peaking if you compare it to other sports.
So I have,
I have a lot more to gain.
I can't give you a number,
but I have a lot more to give.
Filling.
You've had moments in your career though,
you were kind of down,
right?
Like how much longer am I going to do this exactly.
Now?
[inaudible] Anthony Johnson loss that,
that was a tough one.
Uh,
you know,
uh,
but,
but I always told myself like,
you know,
either either,
either I just put my,
either I just get the fuck out of there.
I'd just learn from it and keep going.
And doing it then I just love my life as it is.
You know,
I had the,
I had my,
my,
uh,
I'm so flexible in my schedule and my,
my,
you know,
I'm in my time with the family and again,
everything from the sport,
so,
so I have to do it more and I'm going to do it more.
That's,
that's what I,
if I,
if I probably gonna like if,
if I would like for example,
say,
you know,
fuck it,
I don't have,
after I lost against antique for example,
I would regret myself like a lot,
like in the lake forest maybe don't so well because you,
you had your finest performance after that.
Yeah,
I mean the Glover to sharer and I just feel like that's the thing and I just
feel like I'm just keep going like this,
right.
For every fight.
And then I have,
I have just a couple of setbacks,
but I'm seeing those marginals.
I see the numbers gone up.
I see.
I see myself doing better.
So I believe in myself 100% and I believe I have what it takes to take that belt
that I believe I have what it takes.
And I believe I can beat John John's,
I believe 100%.
I have what it takes to beat John Jones and I have what it takes to be DC.
So I'm just looking for that opportunity.
I want to,
you know,
step in there.
People will say I'm not the active enough.
I,
I don't say enough,
but that's never been my thing.
I know there'd been like a condom or Greg or,
and if I should start doing what he's doing,
people are going to tell me like,
shut the fuck up.
You know,
I see.
Right through you.
You're not that guy.
I was just like silly myself.
So,
yeah.
So I just,
you know,
doing what I do and I was just going to do what I do and,
and uh,
and I show what I have when I,
when I fight and I've been a little bit inactive because of we've got some my
injury now and because of all that,
but you know,
whatever people say,
I'm and I'm done and I'm just waiting for the next opportunity basically.
I can't weight the rumble.
Johnson fight was a tough one for you to swallow too because it was in
Stockholm.
It was this enormous event.
Everybody was there to see you.
And I'm in that fight.
We didn't pick it up while the fight was going on,
but you guys collided heads.
Yeah.
It was a headbutt.
Yeah,
I'm not,
I'm not taking anything away from Anthony Johnson hit that guy is a beast and he
hits a hot,
he's one of the hardest hit her in the fucking sport.
No,
I mean,
no one's taking anything away from him.
He's truly exceptional.
But the thing is,
I would throwing my,
my,
my kick there and he just came in there and he's forehead hit my chin.
Yeah.
And from an,
I just,
I just blacked out.
I didn't,
I went down,
I went up again.
I was in the Ma,
I was in the match again bunny.
He just,
you know,
when you get a taste of blood,
he just goes for it.
And I should just keep my guard up.
I'm very like this,
right.
And I'm very lengthy and he just caught me as I'm doing all that.
But isn't that one of those situations where until you've been there and you,
you been that hurt in a big fight like that.
It's like the experiences,
it's an alien experience.
It is.
It's,
it's,
you don't recognize any of the of it.
It's like you can't,
nothing controls your mind trying to control your legs,
your arms like this and that.
But it was just,
I was just disoriented and then there was four in the morning in one of the big
stadium in Sweden,
four in the morning.
We filled it up,
we fill it up and it's huge.
It was huge,
man.
And,
and,
uh,
and like I said,
four in the morning,
I do,
you know,
when the people told me like,
oh,
are we going to do this?
I'm like,
no,
he's not gonna.
It's not gonna happen.
How should we manage to fill this place up?
Right.
But still people went there to see it.
Then it was just amazing feeling of stepping out there.
Well,
for people that don't understand why they did it,
to coordinate it with American paper view.
Yeah,
exactly.
Exactly.
Uh,
so yeah,
that was it.
That was it.
Yeah.
It was rough,
man.
It was a loss.
And now
rumble just decided he doesn't want to fight anymore,
which is kind of crazy.
Yeah.
Every now and then he thinks about it.
He said he wants to come back as a heavyweight.
Yeah.
I don't think he was even gonna make it to light heavy.
And then now he's saw those pictures I've seen.
It's so crazy to think that that guy fought at one 70 at one point in his
career.
I can't even,
I can't even see that now.
I understand how even did it,
I mean,
he's,
he's neck is like the size of his head and he has small,
he has like this big round head and to make us the size of his head.
So he's now,
he's a big guy.
I really,
big guy.
I ran into him once while he was fighting.
One 70.
Uh,
he was in the lobby of a hotel.
I came downstairs and I go,
Anthony,
how much do you weigh?
And he starts laughing.
He's like,
dude,
30.
I was like,
two 30 you weighed two 30.
You got it.
That makes my wake.
I,
they see man,
I'm telling them,
I mixed my wake up.
I wake at EDC,
I'm about,
his weight cut was horrific.
He used his whole,
his cheek.
She's just sucking.
He has prominent cheekbones.
Right.
So like when his weight cut was fully dehydrated,
when his body was like,
really,
it was like horrible.
It's like,
look,
go a skeleton.
Oh Shit.
It's like,
man,
that's my goal for you all missed wait a bunch of times too.
No,
no,
I'm going up to like takeaways.
He's probably the best thing he's ever done in his career.
I agree.
Yeah.
I was kind of stunned when he decided to retire,
but what he said was interesting.
He said,
I'm not a fighter.
He goes,
I'm an athlete.
I'm just really good at fighting,
fighting.
I don't know if that's correct though.
I would say more like,
I like a,
like a fighter,
you know,
he's a great athlete but,
but I see him more like a,
like a whole corps fighter.
I don't,
you know,
we are all athletes doing this but,
but,
but he's more like the fighter,
you know Phil Davis is,
he's an athlete.
He's an athlete.
But this guy,
he's just like,
it's a fighter man.
I'm telling you.
Got gotta tell him man.
I mean if you watch his fight with Glover to sharer,
you watch his fight with little nog.
Yeah.
That mother fuckers are destroyer.
He does.
He's a destroyer.
Don't want to move.
Don't want to be in front of them.
And that shows you how fucking tough DC is.
That guy,
that guy twice I throw out everything I had in him.
Everything I had,
I need him in the face.
I kicked him in his buddy.
Sometimes I hit him and I saw,
he's like,
just goes like this.
I,
he just,
he just kept going.
It dcs and animal.
Yeah.
Four wheel drive just kept on going on
and he just,
same pay,
same pace.
If I fired him again,
I will not stand in this book.
I want to stand in front of him.
So you think that was the critical error,
like right in front of 100% reach advantage?
Yeah,
I respect that.
He's wrestling too much.
Um,
so yeah,
like if I found him again,
I will do a way different way.
Yeah.
I'm sure he'd do something different too though,
right?
He'd probably do.
You probably do,
but you still do one thing and call it like,
oh all the time.
Just keeps moving forward.
And that's what it does.
What you gotta do is you've got to catch him when he's coming down from
heavyweight,
he sees,
you remember
the towel lay is pushing down on it.
And so awesome.
I saw the idols,
I saw that
I want him to come down.
I hope it's coming down.
Yeah,
he can't,
he can't just snake.
No.
Take that fight.
And now he,
even if he wins,
it has to come,
come down and
defend and fight.
And if he beats deep bay,
he might freak Francis again.
Who knows.
We might fight a Volkov who,
you know,
you could,
who could fight.
No,
he has to fight me.
It doesn't want to fight me,
but it has to fight me.
He has to in your mind,
he has to find out that you need,
that's what I need.
Yeah,
that's mine.
It's him or John.
So John's first you would like to be the first guy to fight John.
I welcome them back right away.
Yeah.
I mean,
I'm trying,
I'm in camp.
I'm not in camp.
Sorry.
I'm training right.
A feeling great.
My shoulder's good.
And I'm just waiting for an opportunity or the light heavyweight is pretty wide
open right now,
particularly with this decision for DC to fight against.
So we,
you have,
you know,
it's interesting like you have,
um,
[inaudible] who just lost,
right?
You got your friend Jimmy Manoa,
you have a,
a few guys who are at the top of the heap,
you know,
uh,
but you're the standout right now,
John being in the limbo.
Yeah.
He's gone.
No,
nobody knows what's happening with him.
Light stands out to you in that division.
Ilir Yeah.
Yeah.
And you know,
I want to find my teammates at radical.
I don't find my teammates really,
I've been turning it with him since I was,
I started my career.
So Jimmy,
Jimmy and the lawyer is,
you know,
we've been saying to each other that whatever happens,
we're not fighting each other,
you know.
Um,
but,
uh,
yeah,
for the,
the only,
the only the only five that makes sense for me right now.
It's a,
it's fighting if finding the top guys in our rank number one right now,
so I can look back,
I can look down,
I have to look up,
right.
What's the next up here?
And,
uh,
if would take it from there,
we take it from there.
And,
uh,
like you said with John Jones,
he's in limbo.
I hope it comes back.
If it doesn't come back,
maybe a fight him in boxing.
I fight him inbox from two.
Why does he want to box?
He's been boxing lives.
Instagram.
That's all he do is box and right now we're really,
yeah,
I haven't paid attention to his Instagram.
He's boxing all the time.
Yeah.
I don't see,
see him coming back as a boxer though.
I mean that gun,
I'm a Gregor money.
We could,
we could,
yeah.
That's another thing.
But we can think of like maybe a side show here.
We can box whatever.
You just want to get in there with them somehow or another.
Somehow somehow or another.
Your competitive drive once you get in there with them.
That was my,
that's my,
like I told you,
it's,
it's bigger than winning the belt.
That's your Mount Everest.
John Joan Jones.
Is John's out there going?
Yeah,
he knows.
He knows that he is.
He's still got that corvette.
Yo sell that thing and get a minivan.
Drive slow.
It looks good,
man.
Looks real good.
Yeah you do.
It's gotta be so frustrating
for him to be in a situation that he's in.
Yeah.
I don't even imagine.
Yeah,
I can imagine either.
It's fucked up.
It's a crazy situation to be in.
Did you see the outer called Colby Covington?
No.
What you said about John John's out.
Anyone want to hear it?
No.
Okay.
We shouldn't.
I mean you could,
you could bring it up if you want to,
but cold he was talking,
it was like,
it was a like a,
a text like this just about John Johnson,
how a piece of shit is
now.
I wasn't even surprised when I saw it myself,
you know?
I was like,
is this right or wrong?
I don't know.
Jon Jones is going to be in front of you one day.
Gotta be careful.
Watch your fucking words.
Yeah.
You gonna get slapped in the face by a guy can kill you with his hands.
That's a,
that's a bad move I get with Colby is doing,
I mean,
he's making a lot of noise and trying to do business,
you know?
And if you fight him,
you gonna make a lot of money because a lot of people are going to come to see
him get his ass kicked,
you know?
You know he has,
he's not probably on,
on the,
on the popper little list is probably on the,
I want you to see.
I want to see you get knocked out list.
He's in a dangerous situation right now.
He's going to fight those San Joe's.
Yeah.
How failed though?
San Joses Brazilian,
he talked crazy shit about Brazil and they were gonna fight in Brazil.
He's moved to Chicago.
Which Colby,
thank the baby Jesus.
I would say the same thing.
You don't want to be fighting Hoffeld does on Joe's.
You only want to kill you.
It only went back close to Brazilian.
Right.
And I feel public coming from,
you don't even want to be close to him.
No,
I would not go.
If I was him,
he'd probably go anyway,
man.
He doesn't give a fuck.
He'll go off the money's right.
I'm sure he would.
But dos Santos right now at welterweight,
I think is a murderer.
He's a fucking killer.
At welterweight because for him that cut down to 55 was just too big,
too big.
And now he's the guy,
he's big and be just too much of a cot to draining on his body.
And then you see the way he beat Robbie Lawler in his last fight,
you're like,
Holy Shit.
That goes through Neil Magni,
Robbie Lawler.
And you'd look at how good he looks at one 70.
Like,
well,
tough shit.
It's a good fight.
Is a very good fun.
Yeah.
It's a really good fight.
Particularly stand up.
He has a big advantage I think over Colby.
What does he do?
Call it bean,
but it takes a wrestler.
It's rest.
He's a restaurant.
Yeah.
It's standup as good.
I mean,
he beat Damien Maia.
I beat him up,
but I,
I feel like my,
uh,
is uh,
you know,
I mean my was coming off of that very,
very hard fight against Tyron Woodley.
Five hard rounds got beat up and then he's going to go five or I think he went
three rounds with Colby,
but I just don't think he's the same guy anymore.
I think he's 41.
I think my four game for a long time.
Long things being in the game for a very long time.
Yeah.
And I think,
uh,
those long hard five round war,
it's like you did with takes a toll on you.
Yeah.
It takes a toll on not taking anything away from Colby,
but I think also think Colby style is probably tailored married for a guy like
Maya.
Yeah.
You know,
wrestling very strong.
See like your breasts and guns.
Brazilian Jujitsu guys.
Yeah.
Right now you're a fucking decent guy.
You don't get in any,
you're not involved
in any brawls.
You don't get involved in the stupidity.
You're an excellent representative of a professional athlete.
Thanks.
What do you think about all this Conor McGregor bullshit?
Like we see someone throwing a Dolly at on a bus and shattering a windows.
I don't even have words for it,
man.
I'm the words for it.
What did you think of when you heard that?
I heard the news when I landed,
I was in the plane when it was all happening flying to New York.
And when I landed,
my phone was like,
all these text messages coming in and going,
what the fuck is wrong with Connor?
What the,
I'm like,
what happened?
You know,
and then I check the news and I was like,
oh Christ.
And then I hear the two fights were pulled from the car and then three fights
were posing with the car.
Connor Mcgregor,
he,
he's just,
he's just losing it right now.
It feels like he's,
he's lost it.
I feel like,
you know,
I've never really been,
I respect all these things.
These does,
he's,
he,
he's a,
he's a great businessman.
He'd do what it takes to make money.
He knows what it takes to get the money in.
And He'd do is he did really good.
He's,
he's a,
he's a mastermind when it comes to trash talking,
man.
He's telling,
he take his place,
he takes it to another level.
But like this thing he did,
now it's just,
it's,
uh,
it's just crazy.
You don't do that?
You don't do it at all?
I don't.
I don't know what it is.
Why is it doing it?
Yeah.
I don't know.
Either it's a drunk as fuck or is it just a bruise?
I wouldn't think that's a booze move.
That seems more like a coke.
It could be,
I dunno.
It just could be part of his act.
Yeah,
but that's the thing like dude didn't take it that far.
You wouldn't take it that far too to just make some noise.
I Dunno.
Well what if my thing is like what of that that Dolly hit the car where rose was
sitting and cut roses face up.
No,
that was just be fuck Michael Key.
Esha I'm sad that he got cut,
but chess is a tough pastor.
It it'll be fine.
He's probably pissed off and he's going to sue Connor and it probably make a
shitload of money soon,
but it would have been hit rose.
No,
that would be bad.
Really bad.
I feel terrible.
I hate the fucking world would hate him.
Like rose was blinded in one eye because of that.
That would be like what the fuck ray board got cuts in his eyes.
It's entirely pipe.
Got Glasses,
glass,
glass cuts in his eye.
He got glass shards,
he got scratched cornea or they all assume know or they shouldn't be.
I don't find out how many lawsuits.
I know key Essa filed key acid definitely file the lawsuit or file a complaint
which will lead to a lawsuit.
I imagined,
look,
I imagine if I was Connor I would settle the fucking every single thing outside
of court because if he loses,
if he loses and he gets a felony,
he's fucked.
He probably won't even be able to come into the country.
No,
exactly.
No.
Here's my thing.
Imagine switching around.
Imagine if Ray Borg through that Dolly at the bus and Connor was.
Yeah,
he was a smoke.
Begun his career.
He will be gone for sure.
That's one of the more fucked up things about the,
yeah.
Yeah.
He will be gone.
Is it,
you know,
Connor is getting special treatment except of course if he is,
yeah,
of course.
Of course.
That's not good for anybody.
No,
it's not.
It's not.
And like I told you,
he's just,
he's just losing his mind right now.
It's uh,
you,
you'd do it to a certain certain level and then you just like,
you just chill.
You don't take it further than what it just did.
So I don't know.
I don't have any words for it.
Money.
I just feel like it's terrible.
It's terrible for everybody in the sport.
Man Dough.
It's terrible.
It's terrible for Connor even because he got a position where he's making money.
I don't know what he makes,
what he made for that may,
with the fight.
I'm telling you,
if we keep going,
what he's doing that,
that the money is not going to be enough to pay all that shit has to pay.
No,
no.
He'll burn right through that.
But he's probably burned through that money anyway.
Every time you see him,
he's got a new Bentley.
Probably lives in a mansion now.
Oh yeah,
he does 100% he has this private jet.
I don't know how many bounces.
I Dunno what you hit menu,
what you call it,
a body guards you have when?
When,
when he,
when he hit that guy in Ireland,
the gangster guy,
he didn't an island.
You had a bunch of like bodyguards I heard around it.
But today cost every day.
They're not cheap though.
Yeah.
That,
that money piles up.
But when you're 29 years old,
like Connor,
you don't even think about it.
No,
you don't.
He's thinking about now,
not the future.
And he probably thinks he's got hundreds of millions.
The sad part of it,
man,
that's a sub because do what he's doing,
whatever it is,
a billion or whatever it is.
It's not a lot of money.
It's going to run through you.
Well,
there's that.
And then there's,
the thing that really gets me is that what Conor is,
is an exceptional world championship fighter.
I mean,
that's what he really is.
All this other stuff is the bullshit is going to get in the way of his legacy.
I mean he,
his legacy shouldn't be a boxing match where he's Tko owed by the greatest boxer
ever.
That's fucking stupid.
Yeah.
And his legacy should be the next fight after any algorithm.
I know what you mean,
man.
And I'm watching over us was,
um,
that was a master.
He's,
he's,
he's been smashing beasts.
It's been taking two belts.
He said he's a,
he's a,
he's just a regular guy from Ireland.
It comes to this,
it comes to America.
He just lives the American dream.
I don't think nobody has done before.
So,
you know,
it's,
it's terrible.
It's terrible to see all this shit happen.
Yeah.
Cause I'm saying that all these things that are happening,
it's bad for him.
Yeah,
of course.
It's not just bad for the sport to let them get away with it.
It's all apps up and they would,
all this happen.
You don't even like think of what has been doing in the octagon.
Right,
exactly.
Exactly.
I mean just think about setting him up with could be,
you know,
having that fight like Jesus fucking Christ.
That would be a giant fight.
That might be one of the biggest MMA fights ever to make him versus cubbies
cubbies.
Let's just record (252) 069-0620 6 cents and it's barely tested.
It's tested.
Yeah.
As amazing.
You see one little flaw in him,
you get all excited because it's like,
oh look,
he's keeping his chin up when the fight.
What's that?
Who Do you think when that fight?
It's a good question.
It's well at the question is can Connor Ketchum can kind of catch them eyes
coming in and if Connor can catch him,
look Coggin knock anybody out.
I mean,
look,
you see what he,
what he did to Eddie Alvarez.
You see what he did to Aldo.
Nobody had ever done that to Aldo before world.
That that's the best strikers in the division.
Yeah.
And what conduit has,
is incredible precision and the ability to his,
his family,
he's so fast,
so fast.
You speed,
he's angles,
he moves,
create an angle and he just counted the shit out of the guys.
And yeah,
that's,
that's all he needs.
He also moves unusual.
He moves almost like a karate guy.
He does,
you know,
like wide stance,
but then knocks you out like,
oh look,
a real pro boxer like doughnut thing.
I'm doubting it's corner.
Yeah.
You know,
he,
he's,
he's the best striker and all of that.
But does he had the conditioning for Colby?
That's a good question.
It's kind of weird.
He just,
he just keeps going.
And just for an animal.
Yeah.
And it's also the wrestling,
like Khabib is,
wrestling is not just a level above everybody else,
but multiple levels.
He just,
I heard like heavy guys,
I'm talking by heavyweights,
talking about cabbies pressure on the ground and be on the top.
Yeah.
Taking that,
that Ciba,
that seat belt around taking his hands,
Moon that leg up,
neutrals to go.
Totally.
So Luke Rockhold said he never loses around and training and he said,
he said he doesn't lose around.
Yeah.
It doesn't lose around.
He just smashes everybody.
That's insane.
Everybody wrestles with him.
I'm like,
fuck,
you tend to go to the grinder.
It's like those fucking guys in Dagestan,
man,
New York Times had an article about Dagestan wrestling and about how these guys,
they have very few options and so a lot of them,
you know,
they go towards the dark side and get involved in terrorism.
I was other things and this is the way to go towards the light side.
They go sports.
Yeah.
And they have a different mindset there through if you're doing good,
if you are,
if you are a,
like if,
if you win the world games or whatever,
they take care of you.
They really support to the whole government.
Whole country's carrying you off from the Mac.
The carry into your king there.
Yeah.
Just,
it's a great motivation,
man.
That's there.
They're just,
yeah,
the animals.
The animals.
Did you see that beat fight?
Who is a beat magomed sharp off.
He fought a on the undercard of uh,
no,
I don't think so.
Holy Shit.
He's another one from Dagestan and not the one that another one,
but he's totally different.
He's like six foot one fights at one 45 yeah.
That guy.
Yeah,
they guy.
Yeah.
I think his background is actually like,
um,
I'm gonna say it's woo Shu or something like that.
I think he started off as a Kung Fu guy,
but who,
who did it go?
He won that file.
BOCHNIAC rate fight.
It's the crazy three round fight.
Bochniac just kept coming at him,
kept coming at him.
And then at the end of the third round,
bochniac finally has him cornered up against the cage and he's teeing off on
him.
Phenomenal.
I mean,
phenomenal fight for the toughness of Basquiat and this skill of beat.
But even with fucking phenomenal,
just this ridiculous tech,
this guy,
not even a restaurant.
He's a,
he's a talker.
He's a strike of Buddy's.
Got Wrestling to me.
His wrestling is good too and it's his take down defense is very good and his
Jujitsu is very good too.
But his fucking striking crazy shit.
We'll kicks front leg,
roundhouse kicks to the face,
switch kicks,
just everything.
Everything.
Lightening fast.
Perfect technique.
And here's a big thing too,
is his footwork.
When he lands,
he's always in perfect position.
Everything he does when he comes down,
he's never awkward.
He's never like,
his legs are never crossed up.
Nothing but phenomenal technique.
I was impressed with to see.
It's impressive to see what,
when,
when guys are like good strike I guess with good kicks.
For example,
John Jones for example,
the kick high,
the kick from different angles to kick it and they just land like,
like they haven't kicked the land light really good,
good base.
They're ready for another,
for account that are ready for this.
It's impressive to see.
So for you as a guy who,
if you had to say you have one area in your game that needs the most work,
you'd say that's you're kicking.
Well,
I think I,
you know,
uh,
I dunno.
Yeah,
of course.
Kicking is one of the old,
one of the things I think I have to work on a lock manner that's um,
I'm,
I'm far from,
I would probably never be
a complete fighter.
I have to work on everything.
You know,
I need to keep my kid working on my boxing.
I have to keep working with my footwork.
I have to keep working on my kicks,
my knees,
my elbows,
my grabbing,
my wrestling.
Uh,
keep my chin down,
got up,
all that shit
just keeps going.
Just keeps going.
Who Do you like it?
Watch fight.
I like to watch to my teammates fight.
I like,
I like seeing guys in my division.
I should be honest to your arm up now.
I'm not really,
uh,
I'm not,
I'm not a guy that really watch fights.
I don't watch all the fights.
I don't know about barely watched in any fights or just fight.
If I know,
uh,
into my teammates,
my teammates or competition fights,
my competition is fighting.
I fight,
I look at the fights,
but uh,
oh,
good,
good title defenses and stuff like that.
But I don't,
I don't barely watch fights.
Do you think it's because it's just too much a part of your life?
It's just think it's important that you have some distance too.
You have some distance to,
to work in.
It is a work.
Even if you're hopping in lifestyle and your passion is,
it's a,
it's a work and you need some distance.
And my distance,
like I told you,
it's been I my distances and being outdoors,
hunting,
uh,
friendly and France and all,
so it doesn't interest me to watch the fights.
It's getting too much of it.
It's particularly when in camp.
Um,
I don't know what try to at all.
I get it gets too much,
I would imagine.
Yeah.
I mean you're probably spending five hours a day just training.
No,
it's,
it gets too much more.
But as like,
I thought if I know John John's is firing dcs,
fine.
Vulcan is firing.
I watch those fights.
Right.
Do you have a guide that's like your favorite guy to watch?
Like a mighty mouse or someone or Anderson Silva or someone?
Yeah,
those guys.
I watch those guys.
Yeah.
I watch,
I watch.
Might Amass that guy is incredible.
Yeah.
He,
he's,
he's has down,
he's the best guy.
Sometimes no competing.
Wonder what it would be like if you were that light,
what would it be like if I only to 125 pounds be so fast.
I'm a fast and like,
do you see my shadow either running around like this?
I know.
Crazy,
right?
I mean mighty mouse is so fast.
One time I've told this story before,
but one time like I grabbed him just playing around from behind him.
Like what's up?
I grabbed him,
he turned and kneed me in the body two times before I even knew he did anything
man.
And I went,
oh dude,
that was ridiculous.
I'm like,
how the fuck did you move that quick?
You know,
he,
he's flights.
It's amazing to see.
And the way he,
he,
he finished his flights,
the one he,
he,
he's crazy.
He's like throwing the guy,
taking that arm bar in the air.
Yeah,
yeah.
No,
it was just amazing to see plex him and took the arm bargain there on the way
down retires fucking video game shit.
It is.
He said he drills that.
No,
it's insane.
He drills all the time like that.
It pays to get against a loss.
It probably gets it from the video.
I have to try this,
try this,
and then he goes and do it.
Yeah.
That's crazy.
No.
Do you do watch a lot of boxing?
Well,
yeah,
I'll watch the big fights.
I watch the big fights.
I do,
but I'm not,
I'm not really,
uh,
a guy that I've watched a lot of fights overall
is seeing.
It's just because like you said,
you need distance.
It's not in my interest in,
you know,
I got guys in my team,
they're like such a nurse.
They,
they own it,
they own the data board.
Did they know everything about everyone?
They don't even train themselves.
They just know everything about everyone.
And that's enough for me.
They just told me it was this,
I asked them,
they're like,
oh,
don't you know,
I'm no,
who's this dude?
He has the skills around.
Okay,
good.
So I,
yeah,
so like when you're in camp,
do you,
what do you do to try to relax and like for downtime,
do you try to read books?
Do you watch TV?
Do you play video games?
Like what do you do?
Um,
I'm actually,
I'm actually spending time outdoors during camp,
during camp.
That's what I do.
That's my way to,
to get away from everything.
You know,
watch what's a serious hanging out with,
with my family and stuff.
But,
but for me,
the real distance I get when I'm,
when I'm outdoors hunting or up dogs or you know,
I usually,
I don't even have to hunt.
I should I just go out there and hike.
Yeah.
Hike.
I got some lands not far from Stockholm.
I go out there and just hanging out,
you know,
sometimes I'm just tracking,
Oh what's this?
Oh that's a wild bubble,
you know?
And I just follow with what,
what are the goals or could be.
It could be,
it could be anything just out.
I like to be outdoors.
Even if it's like 10 minus degrees or if it's summertime,
I'm all,
I'm out all the time.
That's awesome.
That's a great way to put things in perspective too.
Right.
And the guy is telling me,
they're like,
if you put that much time being like you're doing in hunting,
he did that in training or B,
not time,
but just having that interest.
Yeah.
You know,
they,
they all the time telling me that.
So those interests,
things like hunting or a relief for your mind.
But it is,
it is.
And I wish,
I wish everybody could see that it's a healthy way of living.
I think.
Yes.
I think,
I think for,
especially to a guy who has such an intense pursuit,
it's probably good to have another thing that you're interested in so that it
gives you like a relief from not always thinking about fighting all the time.
And then there's a break.
Cause it's obviously hunting's not competitive.
So what you're doing when you're hunting is more primal,
natural,
but also very difficult and time consuming.
Yeah.
Because it's like you,
you,
you train,
you compete at the gym,
you compete in the,
in the octagon.
You,
you're competing in business,
you're competing in,
everything is just a competitive way of,
as you leave a competitive way,
way.
It's a competitor way of living basically.
And,
and uh,
it gets a toll on you after awhile.
And then when I was,
when I was young,
when I started this sport,
I was just,
and I was,
you know,
I was just like,
I want it to smash everybody.
The Gym all bomb it all.
But now,
you know,
nowadays I'm like,
I know my bed and my body bet.
I know what my buddy needs.
Uh,
I,
I know,
okay,
this is,
I found a way where I even,
even if I was doing what I was doing six,
seven years ago,
I,
I wouldn't,
I wouldn't even if I offended duty,
the,
in training wise,
being such a nerd in training and just training,
training seven days a week,
24 hours a day,
I wouldn't be a better competitor.
I wouldn't do better in fights.
Now are found a way of,
I basically found a way,
okay,
this is what I need to,
to make my life better and make my competition better.
I performed much better doing this.
I perform a perform much better having that distance from,
from,
from all that competitive,
uh,
things.
Uh,
and,
uh,
so yeah,
I need it now.
I know.
So where are you stand right now?
You're healed up,
you're ready to go.
Do you just sit,
wait for a call?
Your manager informs the UFC that you're ready to go into camp.
Okay.
I'm,
I'm ready.
I'm ready to,
I'm ready to go in camp.
I'm training right now.
Um,
I'm healed up.
I'm hundred percent.
So,
but how does that work?
Do you,
do you contact the UFC and try to negotiate something to try to get something
going?
Do you wait for them to contact you or do you wait for this steep Emile chick a
DC fight?
Basically I just waiting for them to come with something that makes sense for
me.
And so there's been no discussion so far?
No.
No,
not really.
Not really.
No.
That's gotta be kind of frustrating.
Yeah.
You know,
it's been some discussions,
uh,
but,
but nothing that really,
no,
nothing that really,
uh,
nothing that really account on or anything like that.
It's just been just been up in the air and I'm just waiting for something on the
table.
That makes sense.
Um,
I'm ready to go,
man.
So what would make sense other than Jon Jones other than DC?
What would make sense you as the number one contender right now,
John's on ranked because right now he's currently suspended,
but as soon as they put him back in,
he's likely to be right up there with you.
And then you have DC.
I mean who else in your division makes any sense now?
They were to offer you a fight now of John Jones is going to be suspended still
for another six months or whatever it's going to be.
Who makes sense in your division for you other than DC?
What?
I wish I had an answer to that right now,
but I,
I really don't.
I just,
you know,
I just feel like it has to be,
it has to be on unmeaningful offer.
It has to be something that I feel this is strike,
this is this is what I,
what I want.
I feel like man,
in my position in my career right now,
every fight I refine it has to mean something and I'm getting at is with you at
the top.
Yeah.
Really the fight to make is one of two D C or John.
Those are the two fights.
Yeah.
Or,
or it could be something else to Joe.
But it has to be,
it has to be,
has to fit right though.
It has to fit right.
And,
and,
uh,
it has to be,
has to be something meaningful,
like a big main event on Fox or something like that.
Something where it's a big fight to showcase something good.
And,
you know,
everybody knows that when I'm stepping up in that octagon,
I'm going to perform and I'm going to make a show and I'm looking for that goal.
That's all I'm saying.
Well,
listen,
man,
uh,
I'm a fan.
It's been a pleasure to be able to commentate your fights.
I really enjoy watching fight.
I really enjoy watch you develop the whole process.
And,
uh,
I really appreciate you coming on here,
man.
Appreciate it.
Good luck to you.
I appreciate that.
The mauler ladies and gentlemen.
Hm.